what's going on guys today my girlfriend
who knows
nothing about anime will be guessing the
quirks and the hero names
of a bunch of different characters from
my academia after she's made her guesses
i'll explain
what powers the characters actually have
and we'll see how close she was to the
right answer
how are you feeling today i'm excited
you feel like
i didn't do too bad last time so yeah
yeah for those that don't know this is
the second time
laverne has been on my channel um we did
it about like a month
ago now was it yeah yeah so this time
i'm gonna have another bite of the
cherry you know you did
not too bad last time i think but let's
get into it and see how you do this time
okay so the first character i have for
you is this man right
here what are your immediate thoughts
about what his quirk might be and what
his name might be
so my first thought um was that
i don't know if you've seen princess and
the frog but the voodoo man looks just
like this i haven't seen that
like the style because of that i'm
thinking of like mystical
like voodoo sort of thing and like the
cane as well
it really makes me think that you know
yeah black magic voodoo type thing okay
so what's your guess on what his quirk
is so his quirk is magic um
maybe talk to the shadows and things and
summon the shadows and things like that
this is
just because of a princess in the frog
but he can summon the shadows so like
they can
move you attack you and things like that
so he's always in the dark
and what do you think his name might be
fuji man
voodoo man yeah hero or villain do you
think villain absolutely a villain
okay so you are right he he is a villain
um and to be honest your guess wasn't
too bad like he is a former magician
like he is a
very theatrical he's not okay he's a bit
of a performer so you see that little
marble in his hand
yeah so i should have yeah yeah yeah so
that was a bit of a clue
he can basically turn compress anything
into a marble
so if you have a car he can turn into a
marble if you have a tv
you can even turn people into marbles
and you can just carry them around in
his pocket
so it's a really powerful question so
specific does he know what marbles what
so if i put
a car a person and a dog yeah
in a marvel and i put them in my pocket
will i be able to differentiate
yeah you can because when when you look
at the marbles really close you can see
what's inside them
and is it irreversible it's reversible
yeah so he oh
yeah he can reverse it so if he chooses
to if he clicks his fingers then the
thing will turn
from a marble back into what it was is
you're conscious in the marble
are you aware that you've been turned
into a marble this is a debate this has
been a debate yeah i think it's that
they're not conscious when they're in
there
um because back ago was actually turned
into a marble
oh yeah but but i don't know if he was
conscious in there
um it's never really made clear if he is
or not
but i just assume that they're in
suspended animation they don't know
what's going on
okay yeah um did i tell you his name his
name is mr compress
oh okay yeah it's kind of what you would
expect yeah
um see let's move on to the next
character okay
is this not who i guess was misty last
time no no this is a different so last
time the character you guessed was misty
was actually toga
but this is someone else okay
are those bunny ears i feel like she's
got bunny ears that's so cute
yeah i want to call her misty now but
anyway um
any female just misty yeah like cute and
like
quirky she looks really fit um
i think she's super fast no no she can
jump really high like a rabbit
so i think that she can literally like
jump
the length the not the length the size
of a building like i feel like she's
just super bouncy
just because i feel like she looks like
a rabbit um
and i feel like her name okay i can't
have misty
i feel like she's a hero um
her name bouncy
that's not bad bounce girl bounce girl
okay yeah this is again good guesses so
you're basically right on her quirk
um so her quirk is uh the name of it is
rabbit and she can do anything a rabbit
can do
so eat lettuce i mean yeah
i could do that um but yeah you don't
no yeah i don't really you have to force
me um
so those ears those bunny ears are
actually like real they're actually part
of her
um and she can hear really well using
these ears
she also has these rabbit survival
instincts so if there's danger she knows
you know she knows what's up before
anyone else does um that is adorable
yeah she has a cute little um like tail
like a rabbit yeah like a rabbit but you
can't see in this picture but she has
one and
most importantly you know this is the
thing that everyone knows her for her
tree trunk
thighs all right they're just incredible
um and she can jump super high like you
said
and she can also decapitate people if
she wants
her legs are like that strong she's a
hero she's a hero yeah she never
decapitates
people but she decapitates monsters and
stuff like that i
want to see a full picture of this okay
i'll show you i'll show you after this
i stand her what's her name mirko
miracle
mirko yeah i love him i like her yeah
she's awesome she's awesome awesome yeah
let's move on to the next person
oh my goodness yeah what vibes does he
give off creepy
you're not wrong just creepy
i i don't even know where to start
i think the mixture of casual with class
is hilarious like why are you wearing
fur but with like a parker jacket
um happy is wearing a mask
okay so quirk okay
i feel like he can't talk
why'd you say that because the mask
because of the yeah it's almost like a
uh like something muffling his his face
so i feel like he
can't talk but the way his hands are the
way his gloves are i feel like
i feel like he can make you do stuff so
when he moves his hands
like if he moved like his right arm my
right arm would lift
so i feel like he can make people do
stuff and that they don't really want to
do
so and i also feel like he's a villain
um
and i feel like his villain name is trix
because he can make you do tricks you
should be a writer
um so that was decent um so his villain
name you're right he's a villain
and his villain name is overhaul and he
has what i think is
perhaps the best quirk in my academia
it's definitely the one that i would
have if i was in this universe
he can manipulate mata basically so he
could touch you with one finger and you
would explode if he wanted to
or he could touch you and someone else
and then combine you two like honestly
it's incredible like he just manipulates
whatever he touches
and one of his most famous you know his
famous uses of this quirk
was to um touch the ground and then
create all these different spikes out of
the ground
yeah so he's a villain you can see that
and he he wears those gloves most of the
time but when he gets serious
he starts to take him off that's when
you know he's like not playing games
because that's really scary
yeah he's proper scary he's proper scary
but he's also a germaphobe
okay that's why he wears the mask and
his hands stay clean
he would be fine in this pandemic oh
yeah
yeah for sure what do you think of this
guy
um okay so he
he's got the uniform on so
i feel like he's not a villain even
though he looks really mean
yeah he's not a villain no yeah he's a
hero just because he's got the uniform
you a yeah yeah you a uniform
i'm subconsciously learning yes i'm not
gonna watch but i know
we'll get you so he's got the uniform so
i know he's a hero but
he looks quite serious he looks he looks
quite serious
this picture gives me no indication of
what he just sees just a person standing
here
so i'm gonna have to go like full-on
freestyle here
we're going to incorporate the fact that
his hair
is purple but i feel like okay i feel
like his hair is purple
but depending on his emotion because he
looks quite broody here
and i feel like depending on his emotion
his hair will change color
interesting so when he's angry his hair
will change color and each color will be
associated to a feeling
it may not have to be really obvious
like red means anger but like it can
yeah his yeah that's what i feel like so
he's mood dependent
and his hair changes when he feels
something oh but then he would have to
have a natural power like that yeah what
does that even
really do anything against the villain
well okay so maybe he'll get
powers depending like depending on that
mood and that hair change color
will depend on the power that he has so
when he's angry and his hair will change
a different color
then he'll get like fire like do you
know what i mean um
when he's standoffish when he's
standoffish when he's moody
um and he's quite cold then he can do
ice oh
this is blue yeah and when he's happy
then he can like
i don't know have another type of power
and so do you know what i mean like it
the power will be dependent on the mood
i love that i look it's not it's not
anywhere close but i love it
i might be onto something here i might
maybe i shouldn't be putting this in the
video
yeah you should be writing your own
characters well
i mean you kind of guess i mean no wait
i didn't get a name oh yeah guess the
name first
the hero name is mood
well to be honest he doesn't actually
have a hero name that we know yet
um he has an he has a normal name which
is shinzo
okay and he's a bit of a fan favorite
actually a lot of people like him
including myself um but you kind of said
it earlier like
it's hard to guess what his quirk is
just from looking at him yeah and this
is true not just of this picture but of
most pictures you would never normally
guess it
um so his quirk is called brainwash so
when he says something
if someone replies to him he can choose
to brainwash them
and when someone's brainwashed they're
basically in a trance in which they do
whatever he says
and we saw this during season two of my
hero he brainwashed deku
and then just told him to walk out the
ring because they were having a bit of a
fight
and yeah it's pretty powerful ability
and the reason he looks so moody here is
because
essentially he wanted to be on the hero
course he wants to be a hero
but he didn't get in and so he's kind of
like essentially fighting for his life
trying to get onto the hero course now
all right and so yeah he's really
serious about everything
and uh he doesn't make too many jokes
so if he spoke to me and i
stayed silent he couldn't brainwash
couldn't brainwash you know that's so
specific
it's very effective against people who
don't know his ability yeah so like once
you tommy wants i would just try and
keep as quiet as possible around him
but it also it's affected his
relationships ever since he was young
like when he was in middle school people
would just act weird around him because
they're like oh i don't want you to
brainwash me
um so as you can imagine like it'd be
weird speaking to someone when you know
they can just flick the switch and you
know control you and so
when you're being brainwashed are you
aware that you are being
being brainwashed and afterwards do you
have a recollection that you were
for deku he kind of was aware but for
everyone else that we've seen
um they kind of just they yeah it's not
really
do you remember your brainwash
afterwards afterwards
yes i from memory i think you do um one
of the characters who was brainwashed
his name's odero
and when he came out of the trance he
kind of didn't realize what happened at
first but then after a while he was like
oh crap i was brainwashed that kind of
reminds me of um
alison hargreaves from umbrella academy
oh
when she rumors someone yeah yeah yeah
and they're under like a
they're trump they're under a trance and
they've been brainwashed but afterwards
they're just they're not quite sure so
that's why i was asking yeah it's bit
like that
cool this is the guy he's everywhere
yeah i
um he's on your laptop he's
on your march yep yeah i do love this
guy
oh i'm going to kind of ruin it because
i know his name do you know his name
yeah you probably do by now right yeah
i've heard you say it okay say the name
what's his name
hawks yeah you're right yay okay i
shouldn't have told you i should have
just
pretended i knew i'd have been very
suspicious
um so what do you think hawks's quirk
might be that he can fly
he's a hawk he's got wings that is
actually true but there's other stuff to
it though
yeah oh okay when he is up
in the air maybe he has like an amazing
vision
that he can like look into the buildings
that he's flying over
okay okay like homeland that's the only
reason why i was saying that
x-ray type of thing yeah um
[Music]
yeah that's that's all i can guess he's
a good look he's cute he's got his
thumbs up he's a nice guy
and yeah he looks really encouraging
really nice really
yeah supportive a supportive friend yeah
and he yeah a hero
yeah so he's a hero he's actually the
number two ranked hero in japan
which is a pretty big deal because there
are like thousands of heroes who's
number one
number one is a guy called endeavour and
we actually uh talked about him in the
first video we did
he's the guy who could control fire and
you thought he was a villain oh okay
yeah yeah so he's the number one and
then hawks is number two
and his quirk is called fierce wings so
yeah
obviously as you guessed he can fly um
but one thing that makes him
special a bit is that each individual
feather he can control them with his
mind
yeah each individual so he can like
shoot off certain feathers and like make
them do their own tasks so for example
um one time he used to use some feathers
to save a dog from being run over by a
truck
and then another time there was a
building that was collapsing and he sent
like hundreds of feathers in there to
pick people up by their like buy their
shirts and take them out the building
say
these are adorable yeah so it's really
really bad the feathers come back and
attach themselves they come back and
attach themselves yeah
but sometimes um if his feathers get
destroyed or burnt up
it takes him about two days to go them
back okay does he feel
that when they're being destroyed oh
no i don't think he feels the pain or
anything like that but he's aware like
he's aware of each feather
that is adorable yeah and there's one
other thing about his power that i was
going to mention
oh yeah it was that certain feathers
they're like really long and really
sharp so you can use them as swords so
you can like literally like cut through
you if you wanted to
wow so yeah so good ability good ability
and last character we got this boy who's
very popular i might add he's very
popular
in the community i feel like um
he can turn into an animal
why'd you say that just because his
teeth look like
oh yeah i see that quite yeah the way
his teeth are like
shaped and like yeah
i feel like he can turn into an animal
i'm not sure what animal but i feel like
he can turn
right morph into an animal yeah that's
just what i'm going with
um villain or hero
i said uh i've i think i said it he's a
hero oh okay
name yeah what rocky
i like that rocky you know what when you
hear what this quirk is you're actually
gonna realize that was a pretty good
guess
okay okay so his real quirk is called
hardening
and uh basically he can harden his skin
to make it as hard as a rock
oh yeah okay and he has this uh special
move which is called red riot
unbreakable because his hero name is red
riot and when he goes unbreakable like
everything gets super hard like even his
eyes get like rock hard oh that makes me
uncomfortable yeah
everything about him is just super super
hard um so he can withstand things that
other people wouldn't be able to such as
you know he can walk through fire stuff
like that um
so it's really impressive really
impressive um and he is uh
he's like very chivalrous as well so
he's like a nice guy he's all about
chivalry
so he's a hero he's a hero yeah he's a
hero um
and he's like i said he's super popular
everyone really loves him
what's his name uh his real name is
kiroshima and then his hero name is red
riot
okay but yeah that concludes our
guessing of quirks
for this video i think you did pretty
well overall that was fun yeah
yeah i think it was better this time
around because uh a lot of people were
saying on the last video that i should
have
told you what the quirks were yeah there
and then so we've done that this time
um are you down to do this again in the
future
is there more there's so many here of
course so much
i feel like i just showed you only like
six characters of course there's there's
way more way way more we can do this
forever
that's crazy yeah that just takes so
much to think of so many people
and so much that's crazy that's why
horikoshi is the goat
horukoshi is just he's amazing he's
horokoshi
he he writes this stuff oh
shout out to him um
but yeah you got any got anything to say
to uh to your viewers
i hope everyone's having a good day
awesome awesome oh and also
i want to watch steven's universe since
everybody said i sounded like a
character from there
yeah yeah yeah that's so true isn't it
um what was the character name like
garnet or something
yeah that was it something like that
voiced by a style yeah
yeah yeah that's so funny well i mean
you could be a voice actor who knows
watch this space
yeah okay well thanks for watching guys
and until the next one
peace out bye